(digital tones beeping)
- Our next speaker,
which I did introduce for our
mobile consult service panel,
but I will briefly
introduce Dr. Ihle again.
She is a psychiatrist
extraordinaire from UCSF
and part of our Mobile
Service Consult Team.
And Dr. Ihle, where are you
here, somewhere, here you are.
Currently the Director of the
Community Consultation Program
in the Division of Child and
Adolescent Psychiatry at UCSF
and the interim Medical
Director of the Division
of Infant, Child and Adolescent Psychiatry
at San Francisco General Hospital.
And today she is gonna talk
to us, it's a long title here,
but it's Psychopharmacology for Anxiety
and Stress-Related
Behavioral Dysregulation
in Neurodevelopmental Disorders.
Dr. Ihle, thank you.
(audience applauding)
- Well thank you for having me again,
and for that introduction.
And yes, the title is
long because I wanted
to be sure that everyone
was clear about what it is
that we're gonna be talking about.
And that it is a mouthful but
it does kind of encapsulate
the extent to which these
disorders take up a lot
of time and space in terms of our patients
and our families and the
people who take care of them.
Anxiety disorders are really important,
especially when we include
stress-related disorders
and I'll go through how we're
distinguishing those momentarily.
So I still don't have
anything to disclose.
And so in terms of our overview,
what's I think the most important piece
to this presentation might
be is that anxiety symptoms,
as well as fear responses
often go unrecognized.
These are internal states
and often when individuals
finally come to clinical attention,
it's because these symptoms have gotten
to be quite severe.
And when we talk about internal states,
we use that term to
distinguish from externalizing
behaviors, so things that
we typically think about
when we are thinking about
outbursts or tantrums
or dysregulated behavior.
And so the issues are
complicated in that again
these symptoms are internal.
And so clinicians tend to be unaccustomed
to even considering these
symptoms in the setting
of neurodevelopmental disorders.
Again they're not obvious and so they tend
to go unrecognized.
And then when and if they are recognized,
then we are also facing this issue
of diagnostic overshadowing
which means these symptoms
basically get attributed to the
neurodevelopmental disorder.
They're not seen as something
different or separate
from the neurodevelopmental disorder.
And then even more important I
think than this clarification
of the symptoms is the idea
that when these symptoms
go unrecognized, they cause
a great deal of suffering.
And related to that suffering is morbidity
that is unnecessary because
these symptoms can be treated
and hence the third point.
Effective treatment does exist.
And so that will be the focus
of my presentation today.
I wanted to highlight the
fact that even though my title
is focused on the
pharmacologic interventions,
I also want to highlight the fact that
there are non-pharmacologic interventions
and I'll actually touch on a few of those
toward the end of my presentation.
So the learning objectives
that I included here
are pretty concrete.
I acknowledge that.
So it's about numbers but
more importantly I think,
instead of focusing on the
concrete learning objectives,
if we think about the more abstract idea
that in neurodevelopmental
disorders, there often is
a lot of anxiety.
Some of our local experts
here at UCSF and Stanford
and Davis suggest that
anxiety is basically part
of the diaphysis of, at least in terms
of autism spectrum disorders
and that we might even think
about some of the symptoms
of autism as being
on the spectrum of anxiety disorders.
Again, this is personal communication.
This is their opinion,
but I thought it was
an interesting point that
I thought I should transmit
to this audience as well.
So that's the more abstract objective
that anxiety disorders and
symptoms are quite prevalent
and it's really important
to be able to identify them
and then treat them.
So I've been talking
around anxiety symptoms
and so here I am actually
going to go into more detail.
So as I mentioned just
a moment ago, they are,
they're considered prominent features
of autism spectrum disorders and likely
neurodevelopmental disorders
writ large as well.
And many studies have suggested
that anxiety disorder,
not just the symptoms but
a comorbid anxiety disorder
is present in roughly 40% of individuals
with autism spectrum disorders.
And we consider them
separate disorders because
the anxiety symptoms,
not the autism symptoms,
but the anxiety symptoms
are the ones that interfere
with daily functioning and that cause
impairment or distress.
And these symptoms, these
distressing or interfering
symptoms include a number
of items on this list.
So the need for perfectionism,
for doing things
just so and not tolerating
things that are not perfect,
things that are not lined
up the way they have them
or things that are suddenly
in a different place
from where they were left.
Additionally there's
the reassurance seeking.
That's less distressing for the patient
or the subject and perhaps more an issue
for the person caring for the individual.
Then there are issues around perseveration
as well as rumination.
So perseveration is, we can think of it
as more of the behavioral issues,
doing things over and over again
or wanting to do things
over and over again.
Rumination is more of the thinking version
of perseveration.
And then resistance to change.
So people think about resistance to change
as something quintessentially autistic
but for kids who are
anxious, not having change
is actually very anxiety binding.
It helps to mitigate anxiety symptoms.
So that's why these
symptoms sound very similar.
The idea of change is
very anxiety-provoking
for lots of kids, and then particularly
in the setting of autism
spectrum disorders.
And I just wanted to
describe a representative
anxiety disorder.
This is what comes to
clinical attention a lot
and those are specific phobias.
So, and again, this is
just one of the many
anxiety disorders that exist, but it's one
that we often ask to intervene about.
So the definition of a specific phobia
is a fear and sometimes an anxiety
that's triggered by a
singular event, a situation,
an object, and it often develops
after a traumatic event.
So kids who are afraid
of dogs have often had
an encounter with a dog
that was very distressing
or frightening and that event
is not necessarily remembered
nor is it necessarily in
the caregiver's awareness.
So the child may have had
an encounter with a dog
that the caregiver didn't know about.
And so this dog phobia seems
to come out of nowhere.
But in reality it could
represent a traumatic experience
with a dog that the
caregiver was not aware of.
And there are thought to be
temperamental risk factors
associated with the
development of specific phobia.
So kids who tend to be
more inhibited, more shy
seem to be at greater
risk for specific phobia.
So again, this is just one representative
anxiety disorder.
There are others such as
generalized anxiety disorder
but I chose this one as the representative
again because it presents so commonly
in our population.
So then I also wanna focus a little bit
on trauma and stress-related disorders.
I was glad that so many
of our speakers today
have emphasized trauma
because it is so important
in every kid that we
encounter, every individual
that we encounter, we
just don't think about it
often enough.
And in my clinical
experience, we don't pay
enough attention to trauma.
And again, not just the
trauma of a singular event,
a natural disaster or
the death of a parent,
but those what we would
consider little traumas,
the adverse childhood experiences,
those traumas that add up
and the cumulative effect
is very traumatic and they
have a significant impact
during development.
And so I'm not talking necessarily about
what we classically would call PTSD
but I'm focusing more on
what child psychiatrists
tend to think about which
is the developmental
trauma disorder.
And again in this
situation, in this disorder,
we're talking about stressors or trauma
that can be of many forms
and I wanna highlight
that neglect is actually considered
the most traumatic trauma, at least
in terms of the experts in the field.
And we today have spoken about
adverse childhood experiences
or ACEs and there are several.
And one of these things is bad enough,
one of the things listed
here like abuse of all sorts
and witnessing domestic
violence, incarceration,
again the issue of neglect.
But you have a series of these stressors
and they can add up to
significant impairment,
not just psychologically
but physiologically as well.
And they can lead to a number
of problematic consequences
that manifest in terms of
behaviors in our patients.
So I just wanna take a
few minutes and talk about
the stress reaction again
because I would assert
to this audience that
we don't recognize this
often enough and that I think we need
to think about it more.
So I wanted to take a few
minutes and highlight this
and talk about the stress reaction
and response to fear.
And that humans have a stress reaction.
When we tend to think
about fight or flight,
this is what tends to come to mind.
We recognize that this
is a stress reaction,
a stress response, a fear response.
And so this we're able to recognize
but it's important to remember that humans
have a stress response too.
It may not be as obvious and
sometimes actually it is.
But humans will have dilated pupils.
They'll have increased
heart rate, increased
respiration rate.
They may not hiss, sometimes they do.
I've had my share of kids
in my office hissing.
And they're definitely
communicating loud and clear
that they are having a stress reaction.
And just because I'm showing
pictures of critters,
it is not meant at all to
minimize the significance
of a stress response in a human.
I very much appreciate
that the stress response
is a very strong response,
just that we tend
not to think about it when we think
about our human patients.
And I'd also like to point
out that there's a reason
that we have a stress response.
It's actually adaptive to feal fear.
Fear is a normal response to threat.
It's what keeps us alive.
This idea of fight or flight or freeze,
we don't think about the freezing as much,
it's supports our survival.
There is a reason that this still exists,
that we still have this instinct.
So it's actually a good thing
to have a stress response
in terms of things that keep us alive.
But there's also the
maladaptive consequences
of the stress response and
this is where I'm going
with this point, that even
though a stress response
can be healthy, there is a continuum.
And on the other end of the continuum,
we are talking about a pathologic state
and that the pathology can be manifest
in different ways and
whether there's an individual
with a neurodevelopmental
disability or not,
the distress that the
fear response generates
can have a significant
impact on functioning,
whether it's social functioning
or academic functioning,
there is distress and
a resulting impairment.
And the significance of considering this
during development is
that this stress response,
the pathologic stress response will have
an impact on development
on that it will prevent
or limit appropriate adaptive behavior.
And this is what we are conceptualizing
in this term toxic stress.
Additional features are
the physiologic impact.
I'm not gonna go into those today,
but when you hear about toxic stress,
this is what we're referring to.
All right so with that
background about anxiety
and stress, I'll shift now
into what we can do about it.
So not surprisingly, the
nature of the distress
or the dysfunction will
influence our treatment approach.
And there are quite a
number of interventions.
I talked about the pharmacologic
and non pharmacologic.
Non pharmacologic interventions
include psychosocial support
somatic interventions like
neurofeedback or biofeedback
and psychotherapy as well, in addition
to behavioral therapy.
And so I will talk briefly
about the latter two
treatment approaches.
So when we think about
pharmacotherapy, we can classify
our options into three major classes,
the serotonergic agents, adrenergic agents
and neuroleptics.
So serotonergic agents you're
probably most familiar with.
These are things like
fluoxetine or Prozac,
sertraline or Zoloft and
mirtazapine or Remeron
and venlafaxine, which is Effexor.
So these are the medications
that affect the levels
of serotonin in the synapse.
Then there are specific adrenergic agents.
I particularly like the adrenergic agents
because these are the things that actually
target the stress response proper.
So the circuitry that underlies our
fight or flight reaction.
And there are a number
of these agents as well
and I'll talk about
clonidine and guanfacine.
These are things that can be scheduled
on a daily basis.
Propranolol is your basic beta blocker
and it can be actually a very
effective as needed medication
and it can also be scheduled as well.
Prazosin we use when we
are concerned about kids
having nightmares.
And then the neuroleptics,
they're otherwise knows
as the antipsychotic
agents and these are more
for behavioral management.
So it doesn't specifically target anxiety
but it helps to manage
the behavioral outbursts
associated with a stress response.
So we'll go into a little more detail.
The SSRIs, so selective
serotonin reuptake inhibitors
do what the name suggests,
block the reuptake
of serotonin.
So when serotonin is
released into the synapse,
the way that you stop that signal is
to clear the synapse of serotonin.
And you do that by
taking the serotonin back
into the presynaptic
terminal that released it
in the first place.
These medications block that process.
So the serotonin that was
released just hangs around longer
and so it can act on the
receptor on the receiving end
of the synapse.
And these medications are
helpful when we treat anxiety
in the setting of
polypharmacy, so when there
are other medications
onboard and individuals
with neurodevelopmental
disorders in our experience
with CART and with (mumbles),
we often see individuals
who are on a slew of medications, whether
appropriately or not.
That's the reality and
we need to think about
an intervention, a
pharmacologic intervention
that doesn't have problematic
drug-drug interactions
and serotonin reuptake
inhibitors are such medications.
And I'm talking about all polypharmacy.
I'm not just talking about
psychotropic polypharmacy.
I'm talking about lots of polypharmacy.
So every medical disorder
that can be treated
with a pharmacologic agent,
we need to take into account.
It's important to note
that all SSRIs are not
created equal.
In fact there are generational
shifts with SSRIs.
The older flavors, fluoxetine or Prozac,
paroxetine or Paxil and
fluvoxamine or Luvox,
they tend to have more side effects
and more drug-drug interactions
relatively speaking
compared to their newer generation.
And so these, we use them more cautiously.
They can be very
effective but we just need
to keep in mind that they may
have drug-drug interactions.
I have to tell you that
as a child psychiatrist,
we do not prescribe paroxetine.
We do not prescribe Paxil
for a lot of reasons.
But again, it has a
lot to do with the fact
that it's this older generation drug
and it has way too many side effects
for us to be comfortable with.
That being said, we can use side effects
to our patient's advantage.
So side effects aren't always bad.
And what that means is that
if there's a medication
that causes sedation, that's
not necessarily a bad thing
if anxiety is causing a person
to have difficulty sleeping.
So we harness that side effect.
We schedule the medication for bedtime
and we've managed to use that medication
even more effectively than otherwise.
So side effects aren't
necessarily a bad thing.
It's just important to know what they are
so that you can use
them to your advantage.
It's also important to
recognize pharmacokinetics
and pharmacodynamics.
That's the reason that we
have to learn these things.
And some have shorter
half lives than others
which mean that we need to be
careful in terms of dosing.
Some drugs just aren't
good for once daily dosing
and we need to think
about dosing twice a day.
And we've talked around side effects.
So I'll mention that the
most prominent side effects
with SSRIs are related to GI disturbance.
So lots of tummy aches.
Some people get constipated.
Some people get diarrhea.
Headaches are also a common complaint.
And sexual dysfunction
is also very prominent.
And it can be a reason that
people discontinue medication
so it's important to
think about that as well.
We also get weird side effects
like increased sweating.
Some people do become more agitated
and there is still the black
box warning on antidepressants.
So there were some controversial findings
about antidepressants in general.
It started out with just SSRIs and now
it's been broadened to include
every single antidepressant.
There is a controversial
finding that these medications
were associated with
increased suicidal thinking,
not increased suicidal
behavior or completed suicide,
suicidal thought.
The studies were not done very well at all
but it did lead, the studies did lead
to a black box warning which means that
when we prescribe these
medications, we have
to monitor very closely and check in
on our patients weekly as
we're increasing the dose
or changing to a different medication.
And this point about QTC.
It's a detail that I don't need to go into
unless there are questions about it
and I'm happy to answer it.
But in the interest of time, I'll move on.
Other odd issues relate to
increased bleeding problems.
So this is something that
we need to think about
for girls who are
prescribed this medication.
So in case there's
already problematic issues
around having periods, then we need
to be prepared for the
possibility that these agents
will worsen flow and that is because
of the action on platelet function.
So there are other serotonergic agents
that have dual activity.
So the serotonergic noradrenergic
reuptake inhibitors,
those are duloxetine or Cymbalta
and venlafaxine or Effexor.
And these are really helpful
when we're treating anxiety
in the setting of pain.
And the side effect profile is similar.
Again, sweating, GI issues.
Sometimes people can have
increases in their blood pressure,
not too significant but if there is a bump
in the blood pressure, then
you need to track that.
These medications are
more often associated
with what's called
discontinuation syndrome
which means that if
individuals skip a few doses
then they're not gonna feeling so good.
And so it's really important
that the daily dosing
of these medications is consistent.
They've also been associated with seizures
in high doses, so like in
the setting of overdose.
Mirtazapine, the alphabet
soup here is a noradrenergic
specific serotonergic antidepressant.
And that basically means that it acts
at a couple of different
receptors, adrenergic receptors
as well as serotonin receptors.
So this doesn't increase
the amount of serotonin
in the synapse.
This acts directly at serotonin receptors.
The bottom line is that it takes effect
much more quickly.
So I happen to like this
medication because its effects
are much more rapid in terms of onset
and it actually has a side effect profile
that is often relevant for my patients,
especially in terms of being sedating.
Again, kids who have trouble sleeping
do really well on this medication.
It does cause weight gain and it can cause
metabolic syndrome and
on very rare occasions
it cause a decrease in white blood cells.
So this medication
actually requires lab work.
So for individuals who
don't tolerate lab draws,
blood draws, this probably
not a good option.
So I just needed to point that out.
So now we're shifting to
medications that treat
the stress response.
The medications that we
were discussing focused
on treatment of anxiety.
These sets of medications target the
stress response circuitry.
So clonidine is an agent
that works directly
on the brain circuitry.
It works centrally, so it
actually targets the circuits
that control the fight or flight response.
And again, the alphabet soup just suggests
the designation of which
type of adrenergic receptors
are targeted.
It comes in immediate release formulations
as well as extended release.
And the immediate
release requires at least
three times a day dosing.
And the reason for that
is that there's a risk
of rebound hypertension.
So when we use this medication, it lowers
the blood pressure, which is appropriate
for addressing the stress response.
But if you go too long
without your next dose,
then you can have a rebound, a spike
in your blood pressure again.
So again, it's important
to keep steady level
in the bloodstream.
So missing doses is
problematic which is why
I prefer the other medication that works
on the stress response circuitry
and that will be our next slide.
Because it's now made in an
extended release formulation,
that is my go to option for clonidine
if I want to use clonidine.
I often don't want to use clonidine
just because its side effect
profile is more problematic
than its cousin, which is guanfacine.
So guanfacine is basically
the next generation
of clonidine.
It's more selective than
clonidine, which is good.
It has a better side effect
profile, which is good
and it has a longer half
life, which is also good,
relative to clonidine.
There is an extended release version.
It is used to treat ADHD.
This version of guanfacine
is known as Intuniv.
But it is actually still effective in
treating the stress response.
And the benefit of using extended release
versus immediate release are not great.
It's convenient, once
daily dosing, but in terms
of efficacy it doesn't
really do much better
than using regular guanfacine twice a day.
And it's also more expensive.
So my tendency is to prescribe guanfacine
and use it twice a day.
So guanfacine immediate
release, I should say.
Oh, and it's important to educate patients
and caregivers about the
importance of staying hydrated
with these medications.
Again, these are medications
that have been used
to treat blood pressure,
to lower blood pressure.
You don't want the blood
pressure to go too low,
so it's really important to stay hydrated.
So that helps with the
possible side effects
related to low blood
pressure and it also helps
with the side effects
that are a little odd
and that's an experience of dryness.
So drying out the GI tract,
which causes constipation
and also drying out
eyes and mouth as well.
Then there are these agents that have GABA
in their name, which is
why I have GABA-ergic
in quotation marks.
They don't actually act
at the GABA receptor
and also in quotation marks is maybe.
So these aren't our go-to
options for treating anxiety
but they can potentially be
useful as augmenting agents.
So when a medication
has been started that is
somewhat effective but
it's not doing enough,
then we can think about
adding these medications,
these GABA-ergic medications.
They actually work at
voltage-gated calcium channels.
So they act everywhere.
So it's kind of shotgun
approach to modulating
neuronal function.
So it has an impact on all
sorts of neurotransmitters,
glutamate, norepinephrine, substance P,
so peptides in the brain.
But what's nice about
these medications is that
they are renally excreted.
They're not metabolized by the liver
and so there's minimal
drug-drug interaction again.
And they happen to be FDA
approved for young children,
which is a big deal for child
psychiatrists in particular
because we have to do a lot
of off-label prescribing
which means that the FDA
has approved medications
for use in adults.
They haven't bothered to
test these medications
in children.
There just isn't a big enough
market to motivate them
to do that.
So they don't bother to
test these drugs in kids
unless there's a market for it.
So we have to presume
that being safe in adults
means that there is a level of safety
for use in kids.
And so we just do very close monitoring
of these medications that
are not FDA-approved in kids.
Fortunately these GABA-ergics, gabapentin
and pregabalin are FDA
approved for use in kids.
So even though there are a
few drug-drug interactions,
there are some problematic side effects
and these include blurred
vision, edema or swelling
of the limbs, some potential
wobbliness or tremor.
And again, this is related to the fact
that it's a shotgun approach.
So every neuron in the
brain is gonna be affected
by these agents.
So neurons, not just in the cortex, but
in the cerebellum, everywhere in the brain
is gonna be affected by these drugs.
And so not surprisingly, we see symptoms
that are related to cerebral dysfunction,
cerebellar dysfunction, sorry.
And then I've saved neuroleptics for last
in part again because
they don't treat anxiety.
They treat behavioral
dysregulation and mostly
in the setting of stress response.
The FDA has approved two
medications for this purpose
and especially in the setting
of agitation in autism.
The two medications are
risperidone or Risperdal
and aripiprazole or Abilify.
And Risperdal is associated
with significant weight gain.
Aripiprazole not so
much, but both can cause
metabolic syndrome or
changes in blood sugar
and cholesterol levels.
So some individuals can't
tolerate these medications.
If that's the case, then
quetiapine or Seroquel
can be helpful.
Not only does it treat
behavioral dysregulation,
it actually has anxiolytic properties
or anxiety-reducing properties.
So it can be a backup agent if Risperdal
and Abilify are ineffective.
Then we've talked about things to use.
I want to highlight medications
that we should avoid using.
Those are the benzodiazepines
and the antihistamines.
I say that we shouldn't
use them because they
actually don't treat anything.
They mask symptoms and
that approach bothers me.
I don't wanna mask a situation.
I wanna treat a situation.
So philosophically it's problematic
to use these medications
but also functionally
it's problematic because these
medications are associated
with a higher risk of
delirium, disinhibition
and dependence, so the three Ds.
Disinhibition basically
means that if you're trying
to treat agitation, you actually
can make agitation worse.
So instead of using those medications,
these tend to be used
on an as-needed basis
and as an alternative, again propranolol
and gabapentin are preferred.
And I mentioned the
importance of monitoring.
So when we use these
medications, it's important
to check on how they're having an impact
on physiology.
For some medications it's
more important than others.
For the serotonergic agents, it's good
to check electrolytes at
least once a year if we can.
If we can't, then there
are ways to monitor
electrolyte levels clinically
without having to poke.
But if we are able to draw
labs then we should do so,
at least once a year.
As I mentioned, the SNRIs
can elevate blood pressure
and so it's good if we
can check blood pressure
at clinic visits.
And one of the SNRIs,
duloxetine, can cause
liver enzyme changes.
And so it's helpful to
check liver function tests,
LFTs, liver function tests if
you've prescribed duloxetine.
And then again I
mentioned that mirtazapine
can be very rarely
associated with these drops
in white blood cells.
So it's important to check the CBC
or the complete blood
cell count, as well as
glucose and cholesterol because
of the metabolic syndrome.
So again, I mentioned that the focus was
on pharmacotherapy but
it's important to think
about pharmacotherapy
in the broader context
of intervention and I want
to emphasize the point
that when we're treating anxiety
or treating a stress
response, we shouldn't
just use medications.
Medications should be used
if the other interventions
still have residual
symptoms, that they're not
taking care of every component
of the stress response
or anxiety symptoms.
So it's important to have
these other interventions
occurring simultaneously or
to precede pharmacotherapy
I would say.
And so I wanted to
focus on a specific type
of psychotherapy which is
actually behavioral therapy.
It tends not to be seen as psychotherapy
but I will include it here.
And the types of behavioral
therapy that we tend
to recommend are cognitive
behavior therapy or CBT,
exposure and response prevention or ERP
and then relaxation techniques.
So CBT has the most
extensive evidence base
of these behavioral therapies.
It tends to be problem
focused and goal oriented
and addresses cognition, the C of CBT.
And it tends to involve skill building.
So it requires homework
and that the sessions
with the therapist are
basically training sessions
that include the expectation
that the individual
will work on the homework between sessions
and that the subsequent session reviews,
how that homework has
gone, and then adds on
a subsequent skill.
So again, just in thinking
about how CBT works,
it's a very collaborative approach.
It's educational and it's
meant to be empowering.
And the target population, I
say here is in grade school.
We need to think about what
that means developmentally.
So what we're talking about is individuals
of a developmental age that is equivalent
to being in grade school.
There are some CBT
protocols for younger kids
so the lower grades of elementary school.
Coping Cat is one of the more common ones,
a very popular one.
And then Facing Your Fears
is a program developed
in Canada I believe that targets older,
developmentally older individuals.
And CBT often involves ERP.
They can go hand in hand,
especially for anxiety disorders
like specific phobias.
So just to clarify what exposure
and response prevention is,
it's basically gradual desensitization.
So again, hence the term.
So you expose to something that
causes an aversive reaction
very gradually with the goal
of extinguishing the response.
Most of the studies
that have looked at ERP
have been done on OCD
which back in the day
had been classified as
an anxiety disorder.
It isn't anymore, but it used to be.
And there are lots of
similarities to anxiety disorders
so this is why I'm including it here.
And these studies have compared ERP
to treatment as usual
for anxiety management
and have found that ERP is more effective.
So I mentioned phobias.
And the problem with ERP
is that when you start
engaging in this intervention,
you will likely elicit
an extinction burst.
This is hard work so you
are likely going to have
a greater reaction to the stimulus because
you're trying to change a behavior.
So you kinda have to
batten down the hatches
with this one.
But if you can get through
the extinction burst,
it's a very, very effective intervention.
And then we talked about, or I mentioned
relaxation techniques as
a form of intervention.
So things like MBSR,
mindfulness-based stress reduction,
guided imagery, biofeedback
and even progressive
muscle relaxation.
These can be very helpful.
Again this requires a level of calm
that if we're talking about
a fight or flight situation,
it's not the most effective intervention.
So, I'm picking up on social cues.
So in summary, it says sum
up, I'm summing. (laughing)
So in summary, anxiety
disorders are quite prevalent.
There are a broad spectrum of symptoms.
It's really, really important
to think about them early
so that we can intervene
early and treatment
is quite broad.
It does include pharmacology
as well as psychology.
And thank you very much.
(audience applauding)